okay next up this morning is by your
graded my thanks to organizers and also
to Simon institution to Omid who provide
it all the equipment which I would
possibly need okay
logic in computer science engineering in
industry and maybe math so all major
ideas that logicians worked upon in the
first part of the last century found
applications in computer science for
example types if you know they
originated with Russell and Whitehead so
friggin a little problem it's system
happened to be country has a
contradiction and the way Russell and
Whitehead solve this problem they
introduce types so there are elements
type zero sets of elements type 1 sets
of sets and so on this ideas use
programming languages so the first thing
any program a compiler does it checks
type correctness but there's much more
so let me say for example if if you
remember Java was a big deal so many
programming languages suddenly saying
Java came so what was the big deal about
Java so when you compile a programming
language you don't compile it directly
to very low level you compiled to some
kind of virtual machine and the novelty
with Java was that that the virtual
machine was using exactly the same types
that Java was using
so that was a big deal now Microsoft
picked up that idea and created dotnet
we're invigorated programming language
research because what happened the
dotnet strange name but it's a kind of
virtual machine Universal virtual
machine much richer than java virtual
machine and any programming language can
be compiled so for example you have some
idea of experimental programming
language if you compile it to dotnet
then you can use any construct written
in any language because they will be
there
computability there were three
approaches recursive functions
originated but one interesting point was
Hilbert who asked who was interested
where the primitive recursion is all
recursion there is so he had to students
are Carmen and Roger Peter constructed
the famous Ackermann function but she
did much more thorough job and
investigated all kind of recursion which
was useful for people who came later
another approach was lambda calculus
which is wildly used in programming
semantics and then during machines
so recursion of course widely used you
can't avoid recursion if you have finite
program you cannot just finish when to
go through it once because the run may
be much longer and you have to recurse
in the approach so it uses for syntax it
uses for simple for implementation
lambda calculus particularly various
functional programming languages now
machines gave rise to modern complexity
theory there was some complexity theory
before there before the machines people
work with circuits and I'll touch on
this a little later but one thing was to
understand what today's seem so obvious
you need to take into account how much
resource you have time or space that was
not such a simple problem many problems
are kind of becomes it's almost trivial
but at the time might look like that
maybe say a word I happen to discuss
with both of them how they arrived to
this problem so cook arrived in a way
angel additions could arrive so it's an
analogy with recursive versus ar e so
polynomial time corresponds to recursive
and peak corresponds to re with Levens
was a very different story
so in Russia in the something came from
those circuit complexity working with
circuits and think about some radio
there is a circuit a question arises can
you can you do that same radio with a
shop smaller circuit using less
gates and somebody Blonsky came up with
a conjecture that you cannot there is
this exhaustive search in this case it's
a kind of double exhaustive search in
our Terms view you guess you know for
for every other you have to show that
which for every small I think a little
bit it's Sigma 2 or Phi 2 1 one of those
right then the same a Blonsky wrote a
paper where he wrote that he improved on
this exhaustive search russian war this
parable so he improved on terrible
tracked in broad disagreed was duly
punished and levin came for 411 this
inequality was a way to formalize this
idea that the rebel cannot be eliminated
it was a kind of informal idea and this
was a kind of formalization of that idea
he discovered this independently
so also the notion the notion how to
count space how to count time model
Theory give rise time result to
relational databases one problem which
have been discussed in this conference
related to to this polynomial time on
structures arbitrary structures not
necessarily on strings and that arose in
in database theory in database practice
because imagine you have a database what
is database is a set of relations there
is no particular order
Morgana's relations now in each relation
there are the stupas and again there is
no particular order for the tuples but
when you try to work with this database
in your computer necessarily there is an
order and suppose a ship this database
to you and then you store it in your
computer engineers another order and
what they discovered that the query is
written in language like C tend to have
different answers in different places
and that's led to the language quite
famous language SQL or sequel where
there is no order syntactically you
cannot refer to order the big
achievement
all this happened before theories looked
at the problem
proof theory gave rise to set solvers
SMT solvers satisfiability module theory
proof engines but of course you cannot
ahead of time think of everything so
certain issues came finite automata
logician started one of them is right
here micro rebel and this is of course
of hugely exploited kind of machines
when you teach computation theory you
write little automata and so on but
Taumata that actually used often a huge
for example lexical analyzer for a
decent language will not be very small
formal languages again of positions a
logician was there in the beginning
regular language context-free languages
while interesting things that did not
occur to logicians ahead of the time
that there are so many different levels
of abstraction so if you have okay this
computer there is a level where a single
bit sleep machine level there's assembly
level level of programming language in
fact there are many of intermediate
languages between 12 as I mentioned
between programming language in assembly
language there may be a virtual machine
rank level and there are many many tools
which work with say compiler takes you
down oscillator takes takes you
horizontally in any place but when you
abstract and write specification so you
go up
one interesting kind of underappreciated
achievement is this so finite state
machines and regular languages are in
certain relation which you will know
it's a simulation like non-deterministic
PDAs but pushdown automata and
context-free languages so this languages
heavily studied but the interesting
thing that in programming Europe the PDA
is a deterministic so if you take when
we say see the recursion there is a PDA
which implements the recursion so what's
here theory of DPD a deterministic
context-free languages is a pretty big
okay so this problem was solved by
Donald Knuth and it completely
revolutionized compiling so before cause
it was art and after that there are
still a lot of art but was a lot of
science so those LR languages what I say
underappreciated when I came across this
and wanted to find the proof I couldn't
find any textbook which a proof would be
nicely written and so many everything so
much written about context-free anyway
my subjective impression it's
underappreciated this is a famous V
diagram in software engineering
so imagine
a piece of software is of the first to
come with some idea then you refine it
refine eventually you write code and
then we test this code you test small
pieces and bigger pieces and in software
engineering there's a very important
problem imagine that there was some kind
of logic error on that level it will be
discovered when you test and if it is
important software it done in industry
so many many people may mind might have
spent a lot a lot of time until was
discovered and then what not so easy to
correct so there was a lot of interest
of due to the levels abstraction in
working on arbitrary levels of
abstraction
so magicians or people who came from a
thematic typically favorite declarative
approaches Engineers also swear that
they prefer declarative but the reality
is very different because suppose you
have this specification written in some
declarative way in industry it's often
written and Zed so now it is fashionable
but still people sometimes the company
goes to some said company ask them to
write specification and now at the end
of this process you have a book and here
is software and there is a huge
difference between a book in a software
because I think I will come later to
exactly that same problem so let me skip
it here and abstract eight state
machines that was the idea so you want
to understand what's an algorithm not
what is computable but what is an
algorithm and different levels of
abstraction have different algorithms ok
so the idea was is there a kind of
generalization of Turing idea right kind
of machine which works on all level of
abstraction and in sequential case and
some other cases turns out the answer is
yes somewhat unexpectedly so in fact
that what brought me to Microsoft and we
we created a tool called speck Explorer
maybe I'll skip it now if they return
later to this if I have an opportunity
Engineers use logic very explicitly in
general when you talk to say electrical
engineer or computer engineer and you
say logic for them it circles logic says
circuits
very early I discovered that they have
many many many valued logics so I wrote
a paper in 1980s called logic and the
challenge of computer science and at the
time I wrote it between 3 and 30 I think
there are engineering logic with all the
and between 3 and 30 and unvalued logics
so I failed with the idea why suddenly
they need many values so if there is a
large circuit then theoretically it's
composed from gate say in textbook they
often say NAND gates
the only gate which surfaces in many
copies but gates expensive so what they
do they do all kind of shortcuts but at
the end the circuit is supposed to
compute that same boolean function so
they need to somehow convince at least
themselves that the circuit works
correctly and so they introduce logics
where logical values may be low amperage
and medium interaction high amperage and
things like that and some of these
logics are terrible
maybe not laws under conjunction and
there is this community who who were
badly needs a logician to help them and
there's a zillion people working in many
varied logics and they are well
separated
I came to this issue thanks to my
colleague at Michigan john hayes who one
noticed a series of logics which people
use them to levels and he realized that
there was a whole series and they are
all useful and he worried that logicians
know all that i try to look into logic
leaders literature and for semester he
and i discussed this issue with meeting
once a week one chooses a restaurant for
lunch another one pays but the real
reason why logic is so important is it's
used in a way they don't realize the
kind of implicitly the reason is that
there are so many formal languages all
over the place programming languages
database language specification
languages even if you go to domains
which are presumably declarative like
authentication authorization even there
there are typically typically what will
happen there are say it's not just to
give you a permit this permit needs to
be sent to somebody who will take
certain measures so that you in practice
will be able to to access the system
so so in fact engineers use logic sort
of day in and day out typically without
realizing that writing specifications
had ever-increasing abstraction levels
writing compilers compiler for force AC
typically is written in C so so in fact
today to explain to a compiler writer to
explain gurbles theorem is difficult in
completeness theorem not so difficult
because compiler for C is written in C
so the idea that the basic idea of for
accommodation is right there have you
written the program that says I do not I
do not compiler you know
we speak about constructive uses
positive uses of logic
maybe in this connection I mentioned
this kind of paradox what seemed to be
difficult may turns out to be easy and
the other way around for example a
halting problem a kind of standard
undecidable problem there is a tool at
Microsoft Research Cambridge in the UK
called The Terminator
which solves halting problem many times
a day for C programs so bring your C
program I thought about it because if
you as a logician you may of course
write something that this tool will not
work but in reality for normalcy
programs pretty well in fact fast on the
other hand tarski
prove the decidability of real
arithmetic and if we had a feasible
algorithm for that it would be huge huge
progress in programming methodology so
they widely used linear arithmetic
because it's easily decidable so all
practical purposes real arithmetic is
not decidable
so if you studied logic of Engineers
instead they studied calculus I speak
about now software industry it's very
different from there is manufacturing
production stuff so engineers that I
talk to probably never use calculus and
even some of them especially the
architects some of them are brilliant we
can prove theorems they could do physics
so they went to industry and made
careers well-paid and do interesting
stuff but even the brightest of them do
not know logic some even don't realize
that there is such a science which can
be useful to them so here is from a real
conversation ok I was trying to sell my
access control language and it was
explaining that the other language takes
a competitor my language is better I was
explaining how it is better so this guy
listen listen and then summarized ok
very language is a subset of yours they
don't have the vocabulary to say you
know one real language may be richer
than the other in many many ways of
course the other language was not a
subject of mine by any means but it was
poor
so there are several divides synthetics
divide so logicians are very cavalier
about syntax we practically never write
formulas we write about formulas you
know let's see B now the engineers take
syntax is very seriously semantics
Devine here it's just the opposite
that's where logicians trying because we
are very much aware and engineers
grossly underestimate and there is a lot
of troubles related to this so what I
want to say it's it's not that they need
logical theorems you know if you prove
sufficient something is sounding
complete the complete probably will
never be of interest to them it's the
soundness that's important it's the the
the vocabulary of logic that is so
important there is feasibility divided
you know we used to just whatever is
computable to consider this as done you
know I have a formula let's turn it into
CNF the fact that it take in general
exponential time was completely ignored
now we're much aware of Pauline on what
is by the normal log space whatever it
is but these all are asymptotic notions
in any real world in any real problem
the the range of instances is more or
less determined suppose you speak I IRS
how many files they have at least a
billion and probably less than 100
billions so if you have an algorithm
that works in this span works well and
then double exponential somewhere beyond
that what do you care
so there are feasibility is very much
down-to-earth if you can speed up by a
5% so he I came back to the declarative
operational so a piece of software is
like like biological body it leaves it
evolves all the time something carries
rewritten some patches and made some
errors are found so if you have a book
declarative in declarative language and
it's never clear whether book ever
reflected the state of software another
problem that the engineers the chances a
engineers can't read this book and of
course it doesn't reflect the current
state of affairs and and you cannot play
with this you cannot so that's where
tools like our spec Explorer comes
because you can execute on any level not
not so efficiently but not small
examples you can do it okay maybe to
leave a couple of minutes for questions
I'll say just main idea mathematicians
do logic they don't call it logic so in
this country logician spent enormous
amount of time enormous effort to gain
respect of mathematicians now I'm not so
hopeful about the future because if if
I'm a mathematician and I go to some
area I have in order to to be useful I
have to become a real expert in that
area the question arises what's easier
for me to learn algebraic geometry of
algebraic geometers to learn logic and
it's possible
well we have time for a few people -
toss-up questions yes I strongly agree
with you your main issue the design and
the implementation and keeping them for
that so I think I think that's what the
main focus of you talking sir this
should be possible it's important that
would be a different talk I would speak
about our respect explore how it worked
and very interesting things what
happened to us now I wanted to present
let's see there are not many logician
say I don't know anybody another
legitimate Microsoft so I'm in the land
of a kind of logician in the land of
ours
written with s OS operating systems so
I'm coming from the land of ours and I
want to tell you what is there and the
logic is badly needed again but the
question is what kind of logic you can
come with your logic and say here is my
tools to show me the you nails this will
not work but if you go and talk to them
so many problems have logic context been
was in tune with our group and did very
useful work which was logical
it was not so good complexity but it it
was by and large logic wasn't it it was
very useful
I think one worse have a quick comment
in the suggestion so the common it is on
automata theory i went many years to
Waterloo where they had a big project to
modernize to help modernize the Oxford
English Dictionary because it was a vast
the vast thing that had developed over
several decades and in order to organize
that it had to be made computer readable
so a professor there whose name I last
had forgotten I found that he could
really see the structure of the element
so its parsing on structure not parsing
on linguistics and that he was able to
then automatically far as 80% of the
whole dictionary and then the
lexicographers could fix up the things
that had anomalies thanks to it so that
was I think a great success for automata
theory on a different level than parts
of me in programming suggestion that I
just heard Stephen Wolfram talk about
reactivating the code for SNP which was
the recursing of the precursor to
Mathematica and of course the language
had been forgotten and the computer that
are ran on it have been forgotten but
they were able to piece things together
and make a virtual machine to run the
old code there are many dead languages
there are many dead machines that the
question of Turing's history is very
interesting too because
so making virtual machines for
historical reasons it's quite an
interesting project because I just get
lost because the technology I dream
second let me comment on the first part
so when I was at Michigan I was
attending a linguistic seminar not
because I wanted to do anything just
interesting so when they moved to
Microsoft there was a lot of linguists
the seminar was sort of boring because
they all were computational linguists
and a kind of brute force I remember
this because today it's not finite state
machines it's a big data and so much
data that it needs to be mined and
there's very different methodologies
machine learning but basically it's kind
of Road force and amazingly it works if
you in for many purposes like automated
translation